Hasbro films reading why is this radio
signal visible white light energy plus
Stone Temple Pilots have no business
being in a movie from 2012 there's no
way the bartender would turn down a girl
this hot when it comes to cooking
something as simple as a chicken burrito
my wish right be somebody's name this
guy thinks wishes are real when the
police investigate this crime they'll be
stunned that Alex starts his break-in at
12:00 11:55 starts his ascent of the
gate at 12 12 12 and then gets to the
roof at 12 11:30 for a full 20 seconds
before he even peers around the corner
once alex is on the roof how did he get
further down and if the roof hatch was
open it surely would have led him to a
place better than the top of these
ceiling tiles this is the same thing
Andy Roddick did to impress Brooklyn
Decker I chased those things work well
no you were still able to hand a hot
girl a burrito after you've been tased
where are the holes from the other Taser
they hit him with they hit him with two
teaser shots both have two proms this is
some of the finest military porn I've
ever seen all the navies of the world
superpowers get together to play soccer
he's not a loser anymore because he cut
his hair well except for the times when
he let the two goals in apparently
usually she's the one on the receiving
end of words like these also he's
already with this girl then good thanks
for setting up that conflict and then
blowing right past this total up who is
still a total cook up has achieved the
rank of lieutenant in no time
by Colonel Sanders actually Rihanna
thinks all white people look alike
heroes self-motivating mira pep talk
cliche Liam Neeson isn't killing anyone
in this scene he's got skills but I have
never ever seen a man wasting like you
then why did you promote him to
lieutenant you're a very smart
individual no he's not you want to talk
about anything who the fuck is this guy
you're probably gonna kick you out of
the Navy since he's the main character
this threat is kind of empty also why
did the Jag Corps call the brother of
the guy in trouble to tell him that
maybe they reached a decision wait I
thought this was a navy movie not an
army movie the whole fucking government
is listening in on this Skype chat but
there's no lag whatsoever just in case
you were going to confuse it with Hong
Kong Massachusetts get it there's a new
predator in the ocean we sent out a
signal and we got back an alien response
you're the only one who seems really
surprised actually
okay you got this close before you saw
anything you are the stable officer ever
and also you might be blind also the
government has NASA and the Air Force
briefed on alien invaders but doesn't
want to disturb the Navy during the
RIMPAC Vesta
this could have been avoided if the Navy
just made Independence Day mandatory
viewing for all cadets also I know this
actor's name but I'm still gonna call
and discount Matt Damon this sonic boom
breaks all the glass except the computer
monitors the little boats windshield the
binoculars the sunglasses and the
windows on the other boats why are
military guys in movies always saying
they didn't sign up for the when it's
exactly the type of they sign up for
that was a cool shot but didn't galleon
ship just make a huge show of moving
like 10% closer to its target and
seriously
the aliens are good at the game
battleship nice full senior you are wait
a minute the cup the Admiral hates his
third in command they must have told
this guy to sit here and scream every
panicky action movie cliche he could
think of until the camera ran out of
film aliens sent attack balls to this
random helicopter base this highway this
Little League field and nothing else at
all apparently because they're never
heard from again
this movie takes the most badass after
it has going forward and strands him
outside the action for the entire film
okay a model an obvious real-life
paraplegic military veteran the
directors uncle playing the cop and
Rihanna exactly how many real actors are
in this movie I need you and your friend
often is marketed right now but not
badly enough to stick around five
seconds and make sure you actually into
the mountain if you can't who can you or
practically anyone else except hopper
gee I sure hope he's not still alive
Navy just now getting a bad feeling
about this halfway through the film good
thing aliens only attack until their
victims are not capable of fighting back
I mean except for the time they used a
hundred bombs to incinerate that entire
ship and all our crew
don't worry alien guy she always gets
back together with you after the first
beating Oh looks like the alien brought
a knife to a gunfight
Mahalo mothers movie censors the word I
mean who does that
it's at this point I realized hapa
hasn't done jack this entire movie well
at least there's no one around to kick
you off the island anymore a horse
saves the day see I don't think that
they can handle the sunlight even more
the world's signs and now battleship can
any alien invasion movie come up with a
way for us to defeat the aliens that
doesn't rely on them being allergic to
Earth you come on up here put your ass
in the copilot seat sir seriously right
there that's the most ass-kicking Liam
Neeson does this entire movie
exactly how many tsunami buoys are there
supposed to be in real life this guy
isn't even remotely hiding the two
senior officers left alive on board are
the only available snipers well I guess
it's a good thing they were right about
that total guest that maybe the aliens
don't like sunlight also the aliens
can't tolerate sunlight despite having a
vault on a planet similar to earth and
roughly the same distance from their Sun
as Earth this from ours why did the
aliens need all this equipment if
they're just planning on using the
existing satellite communication uplink
to send a message good thing this
floating Museum ship has like 25
old-timey military guys to serve working
everyday as curators and who also happen
to know how to run everything about the
ship oh he must be a van Cooper fan the
steam-powered battleship starts up
faster than micro
yeah I'm sure they keep seventy-year-old
ammunition on the battleship they turned
into a museum these old dudes are across
from the ship turning the crank on the
walkway until they completely disappear
in the next shot all these chains are
being blowtorch by different people but
they all come crashing down within
milliseconds of each other sure I guess
getting the 70 year old Missouri ready
takes less than four hours why not I
mean I'm inclined to believe anything at
this point I'll just shoot it already
you need proof that battleship is
dangerous drop some land on us madam
movie sensors the work for a second time
alien technology not capable of locating
the skies brass balls no one in the
movie says you sunk my battleship also
post-credit scene should be short and
surprising not super long drawn-out
scenes where we all know what's about to
happen
Jesus movie steals from Titanic
transformers Ironman the drop anchor and
turn trick from Pirates of the Caribbean
and the music from inception should be
called borrow ship